est-ce que vous préférez Hitler ou
Staline elles vont être toutes comme ça
là les questions ah bon bon
bonjour je m'appelle Thierry Ardisson
j'ai décidé de poser aux gens les
questions que je posais au stade
[Musique]
est-ce que tu préfères ton père ou ta
mère ok question j'aime autant que
l'autre les deux je peux pas répondre on
a un joker ou pas je préfère être père
je viens d'être père depuis trois jours
donc
elle est quand même plus cool est-ce que
vous préférez Hitler ou Staline
la paix sous le choléra c'est une
question con
je peux pas préférer ça je peux préférer
le Paris-Brest à la religieuse
Gandhi bastaline Hitler ces deux grosses
[ __ ]
vous devez partir 3 ans dans un vaisseau
spatial pour aller sur Mars vous
choisissez Bilal Hassani Matthieu
Delormeau Léa Salamé Michel Drucker où
Jarry à Michel Drucker frangin
on comprend quelle est votre punition
préférée être pincée être mordu ou être
piqué alors
ça vous excite ça peut pas du tout c'est
pas un truc qui vous excite absolument
pas quel est le mot le plus con en amour
merci encore ou oui oui
la façon dont vous l'avez prononcé merci
oui merci j'irai merci vous rentrez le
soir chez vous d'accord tout seul oui
c'est rare qu'est-ce qu'il vous ferez le
plus peur en trouvant dans le noir Éric
Zemmour ou Sandrine Rousseau sans rideau
pour enquêter ou chercher un truc
bizarre alors écoute d'une façon
générale j'ai très peur du noir moi je
ne dors pas dans le noir il me faut une
petite veilleuse il faut qu'il y ait
quelque chose avoir une tête de femme
mes frères et moins est-ce que vous
préféreriez vous réincarner en berger
allemand en setter irlandais où on
épagneul breton berger allemand je
dirais berger allemand c'est des chiens
que j'aime beaucoup
c'est un beau chien un peu con con mais
il y a quelque chose de roux comme ça
pendant 10 ans pas de bouffe ou pas de
sexe tu choisis quoi pas de sexe quand
même pendant 10 ans sans manger pas de
bouffe pas de bouffe disant c'est long
mais pas de bouffe à un moment donné il
y aura plus de sexe non plus hein parce
que il faut quand même charger un peu la
mule si je peux me permettre ou de me
faire mettre
si vous aviez un perroquet vous lui
apprendriez à dire tu as fermé le gaz tu
as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête la
coco coco avec la coco
[Musique]
arrête la coco coco arrête la coco je
trouve que ça serait marrant ouais
d'accord
[Musique]